we've been hearing about Apple beginning
to switch their max over to their very
own ARM based chips for a couple of
years now but we're finally starting to
hear some specific details on how and
when Apple will begin this process so in
this video we'll discuss some of those
rumors and figure out whether it's worth
waiting for apples are based Mac's or
not about a month and a half ago
Bloomberg reported that Apple will
release its first Mac powered by an ARM
processor in 2021
apparently it'll be based on the a14
chip which were expecting to see in the
2021 iPhones which will be built using a
brand new 5 nanometer process which is
going to be extremely efficient they
mentioned that this chip will be a
12-course CPU with eight
high-performance cores and for
energy-efficient course now you might be
thinking that this means it'll be a very
powerful processor meant to go into a
pro machine like the MacBook Pro but
it'll most likely be meant for lighter
workloads more on that in just a minute
Bloomberg also mentioned that Apple has
been working and testing a prototype
chip that's based on the a 12 X chip
which came in the 2018 iPad pro and the
testing was successful enough that they
decided to begin the transition as early
as 2020 and one last piece of info is
that switching to arm is expected to
save Apple about 40 to 60 percent on
their processor costs compared to the
current chips from Intel that's actually
a huge amount but don't expect these
rumored armed max to get significantly
cheaper since consumers will swarm to
buy these Macs
because of all of the hype even at
current prices now the most important
thing for us to figure out is which of
these Mac's will be the first to come
with ARM processors one thing's for sure
is that we should not expect the ARM
chip to come to the machines that are
used for professional work like the
MacBook Pro the Mac Mini or the iMac
there will most likely be a period of
around 1 or 2 years where not everything
will work properly on the first arm Mac
Apple has to give developers some time
to rewrite their apps
to support these new chips insist those
Macs that I mentioned are used by
professionals to get important work done
Apple will not risk switching those
Mac's over until Mac OS runs flawlessly
with these new chips and that could take
at least two years if not four or five
so if you're in the market for a
high-powered MacBook Pro for
professional work and you're waiting on
the arm Macs to come don't hold your
breath
Apple is much more likely to put their
new ARM chip into an entry-level Mac
like the MacBook Air or they could even
revive the 12-inch MacBook the reason
they would do this is because those Mac
books were never meant for any type of
professional work
they were meant for web browsing using
basic apps watching YouTube or movies in
doing work that requires a lot of typing
and we're already able to do these tasks
on the iPad pro with the magic keyboard
case which is pretty awesome if you guys
haven't seen that review you guys can
check it out after this video so for
those users they won't really care that
a lot of third-party apps might not be
compatible on day one because they don't
use those apps like MacBook Pro users do
all that would really hear about is
battery life and having enough power to
keep it feeling snappy and that's
exactly what an ARM chip will give you
incredible battery life and great
performance without getting very hot and
without a lot of fan noise which is
ironically the situation with the 20/20
MacBook Air which gets really hot and
really loud especially the i5 and i7
models we all wondered why Apple didn't
connect the fan to the heatsink on the
MacBook Air well maybe it's because
they're planning to put an ARM chip in
it next year where it will no longer
need a fan at all and it won't get
nearly as hot as the current air
consumers looking for a basic laptop are
gonna love it and there's a chance that
Apple will allow us games to run on that
arm MacBook and maybe that's why we've
been seeing rumors of Apple coming out
with their very own gaming controller
that would totally make sense especially
since we already have the Apple arcade
for Mac OS which the controller will def
only be used for so there's really a lot
to speculate about on this upcoming arm
MacBook but thankfully there's a really
good chance that Apple will mention it
at this year's WWDC on June 2nd so we
can all look forward to that but the
most important thing that you need to
realize is that if you're looking for a
high powered Mac for a creative or
professional work it doesn't really make
sense to wait and you should consider
buying one of the current Mac's that are
on sale using the links in the
description below so if this video helps
you out go ahead and click the circle
above to subscribe for our WWDC coverage
coming later this month and definitely
be sure to check below this video for
our new line of t-shirts thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]